we begin today with that wildfire it is
still burning southwest
of the valley being called the sandy
valley fire it quickly spread to more
than
1500 acres since it started yesterday
afternoon
it was discovered on mount podesy hector
mejia now live in the southwest valley
with the very latest hi hector
hey there alex good afternoon and it's
still at zero percent containment
standing here in the valley it's hard to
tell it's still burning but it is
way on the other side of that large
mountain mount potosi
crews are on the ground right now as
well as in the air as they try to get
the upper hand this afternoon
we have new video showing the planes in
action dropping fire retardant from the
sky
they're targeting the higher elevations
throughout the day
the bureau of land management also tells
me evacuations are only
precautionary at this time recommended
for businesses and homes along poto sea
pass road
while the wildfire grew to at least 1500
acres
in one day we're told it was first
spotted
yesterday afternoon about two miles west
of state route 160 and sandy valley road
the smoke was visible for miles all
across the valley yesterday
and it appears it was somehow caused by
a person
not by mother nature so an investigation
is now underway
i think the most important message is
that it's hot and dry outside
and that the the fuels the vegetation
out on public lanes are very dry and so
we encourage people to
use their public lands but use them
responsibly
so in general terms the most common
causes of human started fires include
target shooting
throwing out a lit cigarette and
fireworks right now
all federal land management agencies in
southern nevada
are under fire restrictions meaning
you're not allowed to burn certain
things
a list is available online you can just
go over to nevadafireinfo.org and i
talked with sherry she told me the
overall winds
are going to be lighter today so that's
great news for the firefighters way out
there
handling this fire we'll stay on top of
this throughout the day and stay in
touch with the agencies
we'll have the latest online and later
on on eight news now reporting live
hector mejia
8 news now